Um,
I am really delighted to be able to welcome our guest today,
Dr. Lead Chata Polly who is both an MD and an mph.
Uh,
doctor Chata.
Polly is a pioneer I think intersection of two things that we all find very
interesting here at Google,
which is artificial intelligence and healthcare.
He's the Co founder and Cto of Kaiser Permanente's crest network where he's
received the pioneer award from Kaiser Permanente innovations for his
groundbreaking use of clinical decision support technologies.
He's presented at many scientific meetings and industry events such as big data
three 60 medical m e m.
S.
I'm going to say these all wrong,
uh,
and sensors connected healthcare maxim integrated health technology forum and
others.
Um,
and he's an assistant clinical professor of medicine at UCF as well as a
clinical researcher,
the Kaiser Foundation Research Institute and has published articles in a variety
of peer review journals.
He received his medical training from the Charles R.
Dot.
Drew University of Medicine and science in Los Angeles and has his masters in
public health from Ucla.
Uh,
also we hope that you will keep an eye out for his forthcoming book,
which is coming out this year,
which we're hoping that he will tell you more about during this presentation.
So a round of applause for Dr Chet Opale and
thank you.
Thank you MS drought.
Uh,
and thanks for everybody who came in,
uh,
remotely and otherwise in this room.
Um,
it's a pleasure to be here.
Uh,
a always bought it to come here and talk about a little bit about healthcare,
um,
because the technology piece you already,
you guys already know.
So I'm not going to touch too much about the technology side.
I'm more about how healthcare has changed and how technology can help,
um,
get better at saving patients' lives and also hopefully protecting physicians
from burnout and the all the difficult situations they're in right now.
Um,
as,
uh,
describe,
this drawl.
My name is Uli Cheddar Polly A.
I'm a physician and a researcher and as a scientist at a Kaiser Permanente,
uh,
I see patients in the emergency department,
a,
that's my main profession.
Uh,
but I also do research.
Um,
one of the key things that I found was that,
you know,
when you're seeing patients,
you can make a difference in one person,
one patient,
a time.
When you work in research and technology,
you can make a difference and hundreds and thousands and probably millions of
patients.
And so that's what gets me really excited about,
uh,
about working in research and technology.
Um,
my group,
uh,
crest network is a,
a group of 12 or 13 physician scientists.
All of us are trained in emergency medicine and all of us are researchers.
So we see patients and also we,
um,
you know,
we do research on,
on the things that interest us.
We have a staff of about four or five people and criteria,
division of research in Oakland and a,
we tackle some of the big,
big ticket items like stroke,
heart attacks,
and a sepsis and things like that.
Um,
so I'm one of the cofounders of that group and also I help design the technology
for that.
Let's see.
I,
I teach medical students and residents at UCF.
They come to us from,
um,
uh,
from their medical for their medical rotations in the emergency department.
And I also run a group called the society of physician entrepreneurs.
It's a large,
um,
uh,
group of,
entrepreneurs,
healthcare entrepreneurs who are interested in changing healthcare.
Um,
I run the San Francisco Bay area chapter and we meet every third Thursday.
And so all of you are welcome.
It's open to everybody.
Uh,
you can check out the invitation on Linkedin.
Um,
let's see,
disclosures.
Uh,
I have nothing to disclose right now.
I'm employed by Kaiser Permanente and I do research,
but the views that I'm expressing here are totally mine.
And,
uh,
you know,
it doesn't,
um,
uh,
I,
I don't get any industry money or anything like that.
Um,
when I,
when I was thinking about doing this talk,
um,
I know you guys know technology very well,
but I thought I would give you a little brief introduction to healthcare in the
United States,
uh,
and how it has changed over time.
Um,
and,
and what are the challenges now and,
and how to deal with some of those challenges.
So I'm going to divide my talk into three areas.
Um,
uh,
three Eyras,
the golden era where,
you know,
but a hundred years ago or so,
when a science medical science started,
uh,
revealing to us the secrets of disease and how disease happens and how to
prevent it.
And I called the second era.
I call the Steel Stelara era is where you're looking at industrialization of,
uh,
of,
countries and a huge growth,
um,
of,
of large companies,
large industries,
uh,
large hospital systems,
diagnostic,
uh,
abilities and surgeries.
So everything that has to do with the know building large things,
and that's the steel era that we talk about,
uh,
today.
And then a comes to the digital era that more or more recent times,
you know,
how,
how digitization of medicine,
uh,
has changed and will change in the future.
So that's talking more about the future and how technology can help.
Um,
the golden era,
this is,
you know,
probably how,
1850s or so,
it started around that time where,
you know,
the germ theory came about where we're scientists figured out that germs are the
ones that cause disease and how to treat them,
how to,
uh,
you know,
kill them with antibiotics and,
and a lot of causes of diseases were found in that I would say about 100 years,
uh,
timeframe.
And I have a lot of my heroes,
um,
you know,
being an epidemiologist by training.
A lot of my heroes are from this era.
So I'll talk about a few of those.
Uh,
first one that comes to my mind is John Snow.
He was a physician and in,
uh,
England.
And uh,
during the 1950s,
you know,
there was a,
a bad,
a cholera epidemic in,
in,
uh,
in England.
And so he was the one who started investigating this.
Um,
he was one of the earliest scientists or data scientists I could say in
healthcare.
So what he did was he took a map and started putting dots on where people were
dying of cholera.
And so this is a map.
This is the original map that he worked on and you can see those black dots
along the streets.
And those are the places where people died.
And then what he did was he looked at one area,
which was a very dense area where there were a lot of deaths happening and
that's,
that's where that's on broad street.
Um,
and then he figured out that there was a pump,
a water pump called the broad street pump,
which he felt that somehow that water coming from that pump was the one that is
causing this disease.
And so he put out this theory first,
uh,
until that time people were thinking that the air is what causes cholera.
And so eventually what he did was he removed the handle on the pump.
You know,
these pumps had handles where you,
you have to pump to get water.
He removed the handle on that pump and lo and behold,
cholera was a declining.
Um,
and then later on they found out that it was the,
the source of water that was contaminated and that was causing cholera.
And a,
that pump still is up there in,
in England,
in London.
Um,
the second one,
the,
I'm sure you know this person,
Florence Nightingale,
she was a duchess.
I actually,
they call her Dutchie.
Um,
she was a daughter of a rich person in England.
Again,
um,
she was good at mathematics,
another data scientist and she went and worked with,
um,
with the,
with the wounded,
uh,
wetlands,
during the war.
And this was in the 1950s also.
And what she did was she did,
uh,
enumerate the causes of death in these soldiers and you have this and she
prepared this beautiful graphs or you know,
this is one of the first,
I guess,
infographics,
uh,
where she described.
So each of those slices is a month's time.
And,
uh,
the,
the gray area or the blue area as she describes it as preventable deaths.
The black area is where a other causes are unknown causes.
And the pink areas are the red areas in her description or the debts from the
wounds from bleeding.
Um,
and so she,
she,
and remember this was even before there was antibiotics are,
there was the germ theory was it wasn't even published yet.
So she,
yeah,
just by observation she was able to figure out a lot of things.
Uh,
using data science.
Luther Terry was a physician in the United States.
Uh,
and,
uh,
in the JFK era,
he was the surgeon general of the United States.
He had a tough choice of,
uh,
of,
putting out a warning that you see on the cigarette labels.
And this was the first time that,
uh,
people,
realize that cigarette smoking was injurious to health.
And that was the warning that,
uh,
he,
he's the one that is,
um,
uh,
the person behind this committee that sat together and looked at all the
evidence coming from,
from the public health data.
And as soon they realized that,
wow,
you know,
we are all smoking.
And probably 75% of those physicians,
uh,
including Terry was smoker.
And imagine how hard it must have been trying to look at that evidence.
And we shows that,
uh,
smoking is causing cancer and other diseases.
And so he's,
he was one of my heroes.
Um,
Thomas Dobber,
uh,
was another physician who is um,
who was the lead,
uh,
investigator in the Framingham study.
Framingham is a,
is a town in Massachusetts.
And so in the 50s,
what they did was they picked this town of an enrolled all the people in the
town,
all the adults in the town of about 5,000 of them.
And then track their health histories,
track their diet,
track their activity,
track their blood tests,
blood pressures and everything.
And um,
Mo,
there were about a thousand papers that came out of that study and they studied
for years and years and years and they're still studying those,
that population,
which is now in the third generation.
And so this is where we got a lot of the good data about what causes heart
disease and these are the risk factors that they found,
which we still practice today.
So those were all the great things that happened in those days.
Um,
that changed the lives of millions of people.
That actually saved a lot of people to,
uh,
coming to the steel era.
This is the industrialized,
uh,
nations,
starting anywhere from the 50s,
sixties to a 19,
well,
2000,
early two thousands.
So this is where,
you know,
you are,
everything is growing in a big hospitals,
big hospital systems,
electronic health records were introduced.
Um,
and they were doing all kinds of surgeries,
saving,
saving lives and,
and a very complicated procedures and everything blossomed.
And healthcare became the,
became this huge,
huge industry.
Um,
uh,
the image that is all great.
Uh,
except that it was a,
uh,
it was getting out of hand.
And so I'll show you some of the things I think
based on my 25 years of experience,
50% of what we do in the clinics in the u s he's a total waste of money and
effort.
It's unnecessary,
ineffective or dangerous.
Now you must be thinking,
you know,
looking at that data,
I,
I don't believe it.
I don't think that's true.
I don't think this guy has 25 years of experience.
But it's true.
I do have 25 years of experience and I,
I think it is a 50% of it is,
is um,
unnecessary.
So you must be a,
you know,
when you go to your doctor,
I'm sure you be thinking,
wow,
what part of this 50%,
what part of this care is not necessary or dangerous?
So I'll go over a few things to show you what is happening in the industry right
now.
Um,
this is,
uh,
from,
um,
Harvard business review.
The population is aging,
right?
So one of the problems with aging population is that the cost of care goes up.
You know,
if you're a 30 year old,
maybe it'll cost about $5,000 a year to take care of you.
But if you're a 65 year old,
you'll cost $20,000.
And so if everybody is getting older,
that means the cost of care we'll get higher and higher.
The,
this other graph I love because it shows the,
the largest economies in the world.
You know,
the duck tall,
big blue one is the United States.
Uh,
and as you guessed right,
the second orange one is China and then comes Japan and the gray one and the
yellow one is Germany.
And then of course UK and France and other countries follow.
Now healthcare,
if you look at it,
it'll fit right there.
The US health care,
that's the red one in the middle.
Um,
we spend that much money on healthcare every year.
We spend almost as much as the whole economy of Germany.
And you know how big that is.
That is the fourth country,
fourth biggest country in the world,
um,
as far as a GDP is concerned.
And so that is what I'm talking about when I talk about the cost of healthcare.
This is a consumer price index index of various things that we buy.
Um,
the ones in the bottom are in a clothing,
food and other transportation,
things like that.
The purple one at the top is healthcare.
Healthcare costs keep going up and up and up.
This is another graph talks about quality and uh,
and spending and healthcare is right there.
All the other industrialized countries in developed countries are up,
you know,
have spend less and have a better performance or better quality of care.
We spend more and our quality of care is less
and the knowledge keeps growing.
It's not like we don't know what,
you know,
the science behind these diseases,
these are the number of studies that uh,
the clinical trials that happen in the u s and that keeps going up.
And the 2017 number is only up till August.
So actually 2018 is probably shooting up out of the,
out of this screen.
Physicians are facing,
had a difficult time.
Um,
mainly because most of the,
the,
the compensation comes from a fee for service world and so they are worried
about their reimbursement.
That means they have to work harder,
see more patients,
do more things to make the same amount of money.
And then of course there's a lot of pressure from the,
uh,
from the payers or the insurance companies.
The regulations are getting more complex.
That means they have to do more and more check more boxes.
And same thing with medical legal risk,
uh,
where they're worried about getting sued.
So they order more tests so that,
you know,
there are covered in case something goes wrong and then,
that increases their workload and their effort and their stress.
Uh,
which ultimately saves that,
you know,
this is a survey from medscape,
um,
uh,
which shows that 51% of physicians,
they complain about burnout.
That's a sad thing if,
uh,
if half of our physicians are not feeling good about their jobs,
about their workload,
um,
on the technology side as you have no,
uh,
as you know,
um,
you know,
data availability,
there's a lot of data being collected at thousand fold increase,
hardware speeds are increasing and the algorithms are getting better and better.
So now we come to the current age,
which is the digital era.
Um,
this is where I,
I will talk about some of the solutions are how to tackle these problems that we
have seen that have grown out of the industrial era or the steel era.
Um,
now we have a,
you know,
all 80% of the medical records are digitized,
uh,
are,
you know,
he had charged are pretty,
um,
prevalent.
Uh,
hopefully the efficiency will get better and the quality will get better.
And of course,
artificial intelligence seems to be,
uh,
getting inroads into healthcare and which seems,
which,
which looks like it promising era.
Um,
within my research,
I,
you know,
I do work with several groups here locally and nationally.
Um,
but we know that this is where,
uh,
I think the biggest bang for the buck lice.
Let me share a story with you.
Um,
you know,
that that kind of portrays,
uh,
current healthcare situation.
Um,
there was a town which has a river flowing through a small town and there's a
bridge there.
One day,
one person was walking across the bridge and then saw a child floating in the
water.
Actually the child was trying to swim,
it could not swim and kind of floating away in the river.
And so he tries to put his hand and puts us in a,
throws a rope and then saves the child,
brings him out.
And then soon after another child is coming along the river and then he saves
that child too.
And then more and more people are coming,
you know,
as a trying to survive this flood of water that is going under the bridge and
soon enough he calls his friends and everybody is trying to save these people
out of the water.
Soon they set up some tents,
some fire and some food and everything and then,
and they realize that there's more people coming.
And so this,
they set up a nice building hotels and the build all this infrastructure around
that bridge because they see people floating.
Um,
and some of them are dying and so one wise person comes by and says,
Hey,
do you guys know where are these people are coming from?
Maybe we should stop,
go there and stop that.
That,
that thought of preventing disease and illness and depth is what I'm talking
about when I talk about,
you know,
how technology can help.
If you look at the,
you know,
healthcare industry in general,
it's very complex.
You know that you have the physicians on one side and the patients,
which are the two most important pieces,
uh,
in healthcare.
But then you have the Pharma,
the divide medical devices,
the academia,
regulators,
malpractice in and payers.
Right?
But each of those groups have something else in their minds.
You know,
the farmer,
you know,
they are looking at getting their FDA approval.
They're looking at selling these drugs and eventually making profits,
which is a good thing.
The same thing with devices and in academia you see doctors,
you know,
trying to publish papers because if you don't publish,
you,
you don't survive.
Um,
but one of the big things that you realize is that well is their primary goal to
help patients.
Uh,
same thing with regulators.
They're trying to,
you know,
control the quality and a malpractice.
Same thing.
The lawyers are trying to control the malpractice so that we can read out the
bad doctors,
um,
insurance companies trying to hold down costs.
But then in the mix,
you know,
the physicians and patients are getting lost.
You know,
they are not the main focus of all these other institutions that have grown
around this health care.
All physicians want is to be able to take care of patients and then hopefully
decrease all these other burdens that come in the way.
So one of the best ways is now I'm talking about solutions and how to,
how to steer this,
uh,
this wave of increased costs and decreased quality.
Number one,
I think the business model has to change and it's already changing in healthcare
from volume based care to value based care.
So when you talk about volume based care is,
you know,
the more procedures you do,
the more money you make,
the more operations,
the more drugs,
the more hospitalizations.
I think it has to be flipped where when you keep the patients healthy,
that's when you make money.
And so,
and that's,
which is already happening and,
and that has to happen.
The second thing is that we have to go upstream.
When I say upstream,
you know we,
we don't want to spend too much effort on people who are really,
really sick but tried to see how we can prevent the sickness even before it
happens.
So you have to look at not just the hospital,
but you have to look at the environment,
you know,
the home,
the,
the city where they live in the zip code,
you know,
they say zip code is more important than your genetic code.
And then you go upstream.
You know,
are there any genetic factors,
you know,
we look at those things later,
but the idea is to go upstream so that you can attack the problem early on
before it becomes a major problem.
Because the law,
you know,
the more to the right you go,
the more expensive it becomes to,
to deal with the problems
the scientific method has changed or are,
let me put it this way,
the scientific method is there.
You know,
you typically ask a question,
you collect a sample of data and then you get an answer.
But then with Ai,
you know,
you do have the data.
You don't have to collect a sample,
although you could.
The key is to re ask the right questions and be able to get the answers.
Um,
you know,
one thing I keep saying is that healthcare is an information business and the
sooner we realize it,
the more lives we can save because the way you deal with the information,
the way you can analyze the information,
the way you can extract knowledge out of it is it becomes key when you want to
save patients.
I like this.
A paper that came out a long time ago,
uh,
Chris Anderson wrote this,
the end of theory,
uh,
the data delusion makes the scientific method obsolete in a way.
We are seeing that right now because one of the problems with scientific method
is that,
you know,
you take a sample from a big population,
you collect that study sample and then you study it and then you learn things
and apply that knowledge to your target population.
Right now you have the whole target population.
You know,
you go through these steps,
you know,
collecting data,
analyzing and translating,
implementing science.
But then it takes a long time.
It takes about 18 years on average from an idea to studying yet to analyzing it,
implementing it,
and then actually the patient coming to the bedside where the patients are
actually using that.
I want this to speed up.
It shouldn't,
it should take less than a second to be able to get that data in this day and
age,
you know,
we should have access to all that data.
We should have,
uh,
analytics and engines that can work harder.
And this is what I mean by punished the machine is that
the idea that,
you know,
we are,
we have this technology and we just letting it sit there and not be used for the
good of mankind.
A lot of,
uh,
value based systems,
as,
as you might have noticed or understood from,
you know,
initially they used to be a lot of procedures.
I don't know.
I don't know if you remember,
but we used to do a lot of tonsillectomies and hysterectomy is and all kinds of
procedures.
But we soon realized that,
oh,
we could treat that with medication.
Maybe soon.
We'll realize that a lot of this,
the sickness and illnesses can be treated with diet.
And now we are talking about more of the social
determinants of health,
you know,
house,
how the social situations will contribute to illness and how we can prevent
that.
And so we have to go up that value chain.
Um,
want to talk a little bit about what I do?
You know,
so my main key important people are the physicians and the patients and that's
all I care about.
And how can we design systems that'll help the physicians take better care of
the patients.
Um,
so,
um,
we studied data and we'd go back and look at the retrospective data because
right now we have more than,
you know,
10,
15 years worth of electronic health record data and see what happens to these
disease processes,
how do people get sick?
And then you study how you can predict it,
what will happen,
you know,
if you know that this person has these risk factors and soon they'll end up
here.
Well hopefully you can do something to change those risk factors and prescribed
something that will change the trajectory of that disease process.
And so that's the idea.
So we have descriptive analytics,
predictive analytics and prescriptive analytics.
So what we have done is we've taken data and put it through,
you know,
our engines.
By the way,
this is a whole platform that is now active in Kaiser Permanente in northern
California,
which is a 21 hospitals and,
and 21 emergency departments.
And this is what we did.
We created a platform that can then,
uh,
have the engine,
have the modules for each disease process and then have the clinical decision
support system,
which means that it'll tell the physician what the next step should be.
For example,
if a patient comes into the emergency with chest pain,
you know,
we get a lot of patients in the emergency departments in our 21 emergency
departments.
We have more than a million patients that go through our departments every year.
Um,
chest pain is probably number two or number three,
chief complaint we call it.
So people with chest pain,
maybe 100,000 people come through these departments with chest pain,
only a few,
maybe five,
10,
15,
20% have serious disease,
right?
The other 80% do not have disease.
But there are right now there are no systems.
I mean we,
yeah,
we do look at uh,
or Framingham study but then that's a little bit old because if we can figure
out what their risks are and so predicting the risk and then mitigating those
risks,
uh,
giving that information to the physician so that they can implement those
strategies.
So when,
when a patient comes into the chest with chest pain,
you,
when the,
when the physician clicks a button in the,
in our,
in our medical record,
it goes to our website,
it opens up in the browser within the health record and it walks them through a
few steps and eventually giving the physician the answer.
The answer says this person has a chance of 0.003% of having a heart attack in
the next 60 days.
And so you should do a,
B,
and c.
Now what it does is it'll number one,
assessing the risk exactly for this patient based on your knowledge of 100,000
patients before,
right?
So you can actually guide this physician in the patient's care so that the best
outcome can be had with the least cost and least work.
Um,
and so we are very excited about this.
And,
uh,
right now we are looking at implementing an AI based engine and replacing what
we have right now so that it becomes even more faster and more accurate
hopefully.
And we do clinical trials looking at these,
these,
uh,
these technologies.
So half of the,
um,
medical centers have the technology,
other half do not.
And then we track these patients to see what changes have happened within these,
uh,
within these entities.
And so we are very excited and very,
um,
uh,
happy about this and we got an award for this from our innovation folks.
So all the answers are there.
All the data is there,
the technology is there,
everything is there.
All we need to do is ask the right questions.
And when we asked the right questions,
we get those answers.
Well,
this is my hope and my dream is that when we have an AI enabled care,
the bad outcomes couple go down and the good outcomes will go up.
In the past,
you know,
it used to be very doctor speciphic where while there's this great doctrine in
Houston or,
or Boston or wherever people used to go there right now it is more system
specific.
In other words,
while this is a great system,
oh,
Cleveland Clinic,
Kaiser Permanente,
they have great quality,
eventually becomes more patient specific where you can actually using the data
of all these patients in the past,
you can really fine tune the care of each individual patient.
In the past it used to be high touch and no tech.
You know,
in the olden days,
now it's kind of low touch and low tech.
You know,
the,
the current Emr are very,
very,
um,
what was the word heart to use?
Um,
in the future it'll be more high tech touch again,
but high tech will be in the background because the physicians won't be directly
interacting,
um,
or,
or entering data because the data is already there.
Um,
so what does the future hold?
Well,
there are some great opportunities in healthcare to be able to make a difference
in people's lives.
This story,
I saw it on the American heart association's website.
Um,
they put the story out about Justin,
um,
because you know,
they,
they see this as the triumph off the healthcare system.
Okay.
Justin had four heart attacks.
He had five bypass surgeries
and believe it or not,
he had 35 sets stents placed in his heart blood vessels.
That's unbelievable.
It's great that Justin survived this and is doing okay.
I hope after all this,
wouldn't it be great if we caught this problem before the heart attacks,
before the bypass surgeries,
before the 35 stents he had to be on.
I think there's definitely potential there to be able to change this.
As you may know,
we are not doing that many bypass surgeries nowadays because we know that we can
do that.
You know,
we can do it better with medications,
even stents.
We are not putting that many because we know that,
you know,
with medication you can actually,
the outcomes are equal or better.
In fact,
there were 800,000 stents placed last year in the United States that were
totally useless that were not needed.
Autism is a big area also.
I feel there is lot of potential there.
It's a,
a neurodevelopmental disorder by the way.
I don't a little bit about it because I have a daughter with autism so I kind of
studied that a little bit.
Uh,
neurodevelopment disorder that is,
you know,
kids are bond with it and they have it for the rest of their lives.
It's a very expensive disorder because it costs more than a few million dollars
to take care of one child or one adult and they,
incidents keeps growing.
A one in 59 was the last one I think.
And it keeps growing.
And that's what CDC says.
And nobody knows why this is happening.
We don't have any clue how many genes are probably in walled,
but that's only a small percentage.
We don't know if there's something in that environment.
Did the,
there's something that we are eating with that we are wearing where we're
inhaling.
But yeah,
this problem keeps growing.
Right now it's so big that it has overshadowed all the developmental disorders,
all the others.
So this is bigger than anything else.
And this is one of the most expensive disorders for the healthcare system.
Um,
another problem,
opioid crisis
or the past,
I think 20 years,
so many people died of opiate abuse and um,
uh,
during this crisis,
and we don't have a solution for this.
Well,
we know that
when we start people on opioid medications,
if there are on opiate medicine for more than three days,
there's a 20% chance that they could get hooked on that medicine for the rest of
their lives.
Imagine that.
And we all must have taken at some point right after surgery or whatever.
And there was a recent study in Jama,
a Andrew Chang and others,
they looked at really,
you know,
opioids.
Are they really that great?
No,
the pain control was the same.
We'd been opioids and non opioids,
you know,
if he give Tylenol and Motrin,
that's the same even if you have a broken ankle.
And so why are we doing this?
How,
how did this,
how did this crisis happened for so many years for so many lives lost.
It's like the whole,
you know,
city of Seattle gone vanished because of this crisis
because we don't know the outcomes of what we are doing.
We don't know.
We haven't studied it.
Maybe we should,
maybe we should look at what are the chances of these people that we're starting
them on opioids that are going to end up dying in the future.
Is it really helping their pain or is it just
building addicts out of it?
So that's a big,
huge problem where data science I think can help.
Okay.
So to conclude my talk,
I'll uh,
tell you this story.
There were about a thousand years ago,
there was a town,
and in that town there was,
it's a nice,
peaceful town,
farmers living their families and there was a king and he was a nice a king.
He took care of those people.
One time what happened was there was a dragon that came to that town and it
started attacking the chicken,
the chicken coops,
and eating their chicken because it was a small baby dragon.
And so it was coming and destroying and breaking things.
And you know,
this is the kind of dragon that spits fire.
So it'll set fire on those things and so destroys the property around.
And so the farmers and,
and,
and they know that it lives in the swamp out right outside the town.
And so the farmers,
uh,
they came together,
the council meeting and said,
you know,
we gotta do something about this.
And so one of the farmers that,
hey,
you know what,
if we give the dragon the chicken every day,
we feed him,
we take him to his place and put it there so that he doesn't come here and burn
these things up.
Yeah,
that's a great idea.
And so they start taking chicken every day and tying him up near the swamp and
the dragon comes out at night,
eats and then goes back.
It goes swamp.
Soon they ran out of chicken,
then they started putting sheep,
goats.
They ran out of those goats and cows and everything.
So now they said,
okay,
well we have our kids,
let's give our children to the dragon.
And so they started tying these kids.
So the dragon keeps eating and the dragon is getting bigger and bigger at wants
more.
And then all the children are gone.
Now it's just the adults except the king's daughter,
the princess.
She was a young teenager and
the farmer said,
well,
it's your turn king.
And the king was where he's sad because that was his only daughter.
He had great hopes for her.
But the first,
you know,
he gave his word that,
they will feed the children.
So they tied her,
tied her to a,
um,
a tree there.
But then before that happened,
the king announced,
if anybody can slay that dragon,
I will give my daughter
to you.
In a reading and you will have half of my kingdom.
And so one shepherd boy came,
he was another teenager.
He said,
well,
I'll kill the dragon.
Well,
this guy was not a soldier.
He didn't have any,
you know,
um,
weapons.
You know,
all these guys had knives and swords and they couldn't do anything.
But he said,
I will do it.
And so he,
what he did was he went there where the king's daughter was tight.
He took the rope and he hid behind a Bush,
waited for the dragon,
and then he made a noose with the rope,
threw it around its neck,
tightened it,
and so that the dragon cannot breathe,
fire or can't even breathe.
And he dragged the dragon into the town and then eventually kills it.
And that is Saint George.
For those of you,
you know,
you must have seen some of these pictures.
He became Saint George and he married and everybody was happy af after that.
So the moral of the story is that we think about weapons.
We think about things to attack a problem.
This shepherd boy,
he thought in a different way.
He didn't think about guns and knives and swords and spears.
He thought about this rope
and we all have this rope with us.
We just have to use it.
So let's be smart and save some lives and save some doctors from grief.
That's my talk for today.
And,
uh,
I welcome any questions.
Thank you for waiting here patiently.
I invite you to join me in this fight.
Um,
I'll be a,
you can connect with me on Linkedin as the easiest way and,
um,
I'm open to questions right now.
Thank you so much.
Um,
so I do have a couple of questions on our online submission for those folks who
are on the live streams since the people on livestream or night able to speak
directly into the room.
So wanting to relay a couple of these.
The first is,
uh,
you said that 50% of what physicians do you see as potentially being
unnecessary?
Uh,
the question is,
do you believe that some part of this comes from living in an overly litigious
culture,
uh,
where physicians become frightened of litigation?
And that is why the unnecessary measures are being taken?
Or do you see it coming as a us from some other source?
They said,
for example,
bloated bureaucracies,
etc.
So,
uh,
as I showed you those three dragons,
you know,
litigation is one of those,
um,
documentation saying that,
okay,
I did this,
this,
this because I need to get reimbursed.
Um,
and the regulatory framework know which caused us also to do more work.
But there is a big,
there is a big gap in our knowledge.
And so a lot of it is dogma.
I feel,
Oh,
my professor taught me to do this way and this is what the textbooks say.
So this is what I'm going to do.
Not realizing that
that a lot of it may or may not be true because there may not be scientific
basis for whatever they're doing.
I'll give you a good example.
You don't ankle sprain,
right?
We've been taught,
I dunno,
for 50 years or so that there's the rice protocol or rice treatment,
which is
now I try,
I'm trying to remember what rises.
Um,
so ice,
um,
see for compression e for elevation.
So you have to rest your ankle,
you have to ice it,
you have to put a bandage around it,
compress it and keep it elevated.
I don't know.
Last time I sprained my ankle,
I just walked.
I just did nothing.
And it got better really.
So we don't know his rest better or walking is better.
Is putting a compression a better or you know all those things.
Isis is ice better or heat better?
We have no idea because there's no data.
Our research that supports what we're trying to do.
So like that,
there are several things that happen in health care that physicians don't know
and nobody actually studied.
So most of the research funding doesn't go to those kinds of simple things.
Right.
There has to be a fancy drug or a fancy surgery or a device where you know,
to get to get these researchers interested or the funding agency is interested
so that,
you know,
and so the cost keeps going up because you get these new drugs in there and so
nobody's actually following up.
Even when you have expensive drugs or expensive devices,
we're not following them up to see are they really working or is there something
better?
Um,
and so there's no way to know all these drugs on the market if there are really
effective.
I know they did a lot of research before they got approval,
but once they get approval and once they are in the,
in,
in the market and they're selling those,
we don't know if that works or not.
Um,
the,
the research that happens is on a few thousand patients here,
but then a million patient and millions of patients are using those,
but we are not tracking all the data on those millions of patients.
So that's where the problem comes.
That is fascinating.
We have a couple more that are coming in,
popping up here.
Um,
one is from Thomas Kwan in another part of mountain view and his question is
with the Kaiser starting a new medical school next year,
how do you plan to influence the curriculum to train physicians in Ai or other
digital era technologies?
I'm sure.
So for those of you who don't know what,
uh,
you know,
the business model of Kaiser Permanente is a Kaiser Permanente is one of the
value based care models,
one of the original value based care models that was started 70 years ago.
It's all happens that now it has become the main thing because people are
looking up to it and value based care model in a value based care model,
the idea is to keep the patients healthy or prevent disease so that you get a
fixed amount of money.
And so if you keep the patients healthy,
that means you make money when the patients are healthy,
which also means that we have to go upstream and look at,
you know,
their vaccinations there.
Um,
you know,
colonoscopies,
the mammograms and all those things in a how do we prevent cancer from happening
there so that we can,
you know,
uh,
tackle it here.
Um,
that in itself,
you know,
now it is becoming more and more,
the rest of the country is slowly trying to follow that model.
Um,
probably about 30,
40% of the,
of the,
of the companies are healthcare companies are going in that going to that model
and Medicare,
the main,
uh,
um,
government funding agency for health care delivery is requiring more of these
companies to,
to do that.
So,
yes.
And what we found was that,
you know,
one of the big things is that in,
in,
um,
in the traditional medical schools,
they're all geared towards fee for service.
That has been,
you know,
the tradition,
right?
So that continues,
um,
that's one of the reasons why,
you know,
Kaiser is planning to,
to start their own medical school and hopefully all this training will be part
of that.
Uh,
you know,
how do you prevent,
how do you go upstream and prevent problems later on?
Uh,
right now there is enough data that shows that,
um,
you know,
if you are a Kaiser permanent,
by the way,
I'm not plugging in Kaiser Permanente,
but this is just a scientific fact.
Uh,
if you're a Kaiser Permanente member,
you have 50% less chance of having a stroke are 30% less chance of having a
heart attack.
Just Fyi,
just FYI.
That's good.
For those of us who are near Kaiser facilities here.
Yes,
we have one question from the audience.
One second.
Um,
I have a question about kind of the decision tool that you're building,
um,
specifically around the fact that it takes a lot of information.
So at both,
it both looks at unsuccessful cases as well as successful cases to help
determine what the right path forward is.
You know,
looking very far out.
If we continue to use that successful case and we continue to follow it,
do we lose some of that training information that's important for that
comparative assessment?
And then kind of thinking beyond that and tying them with the Farmingham study,
like the longitudinal effects.
So maybe we would have been told that opioids is really effective in treating
pain medicine,
but we wouldn't have necessarily seen what happens five years down the line.
Um,
and kind of how some of the longitudinal effects are being incorporated into
the decision tool.
That's a,
that's a very good question.
So this actually happened,
uh,
so we were building this tool for a condition called pulmonary embolism.
Pulmonary embolism is where you get a clot in your lung.
It's like a lung attack and you can't breathe,
right.
Some people die because you know,
it cuts off the circulation to the lungs and the brain,
the brain doesn't get oxygen.
So about 95% of these patients get admitted to the hospital as soon as they're
diagnosed in the emergency.
But we know that only a very small percentage of patients will have bad
outcomes.
It's a how do you identify the ones that will have good outcomes and not keep
those patients in the hospital,
the low risk ones,
right.
Because when you stay in the hospital,
you know,
you,
you are at risk for other things,
you know,
hospital acquired infections and stuff.
Also,
it's an inconvenience for the patient and it's a cost for the hospital.
So we did a study and said,
okay,
we,
let's build this tool which can identify the low risk patients.
And we implemented it and um,
10 medical centers or 10 emergency departments and the other 11 emergency
departments were controls.
And we followed these patients for more than a year.
And we found that where this tool was available,
it was very successful in decreasing the admission of unnecessary low risk
patients.
What we also found was that by the way,
this tool,
we pulled it from the literature and this literature comes from Canada,
Australia,
and then what we farmer,
once we studied these patients was that this tool was actually,
or estimating the risk.
Our patients are much healthier,
are at much lower risk.
And so version two,
what we did was we changed the dials on that so that it'll,
it'll,
it'll not,
it'll estimate the risk correctly.
And so,
so you,
to answer your question,
we'll be be losing data maybe,
but maybe if we tried to everybody,
we won't lose any data,
even bad outcomes,
good outcomes,
you know,
so,
and then we have to constantly make the tool better and better.
So each version becomes better as the population gets healthier and,
and,
and so in the long run it'll work great because,
you know,
the population gets better and the tool gets better at estimating the risk.
But yeah,
I understand that he though it does change our knowledge and it does.
It does.
Um,
hopefully for the good,
everyone has time to stick around for a couple more questions.
I've got a few more that have popped up here.
Um,
a quick one from Vivian Lee in Cambridge,
Massachusetts.
Uh,
she says thank you for the great of the chest pain AI application in the Kaiser
ers.
Do you have other examples you can share?
Sure.
Um,
we did one,
uh,
one study for head injury.
You know,
a lot of,
uh,
kids that come in with head injury,
they fall and hit their heads,
um,
when they come in.
You know,
one of the tests we order is a CT scan of the head,
right.
And,
and we know,
we know,
again from studies that CT scans,
if you do a CT scan on kids,
it's bad because it is radiation at a young age and it hit that predisposes that
person to be at risk for cancer in the future.
And so how do we decrease the CT scans?
Um,
especially in kids,
you know,
you have to,
um,
a,
the risk is higher.
And so we designed the study where,
you know,
looking at the kids' features,
how it is,
how they present,
can you identify the low risk kids that don't need a CT scan?
And we did the same thing for belly pain and kids,
you know,
what are the chances of this kid having appendicitis,
which is the most,
um,
you know,
dreaded diagnosis for these kids because you know,
you gotta go through surgery but then radiating them on their bellies.
Probably the highest radiation a kid can get.
Cause this is a large area.
Um,
and in a small child.
And so we were,
we were right down.
That study is going on right now.
And,
uh,
what we are trying to do is we're trying to decrease the number of radiation
without,
you know,
missing appendicitis cases.
Um,
that's a great one.
And then,
so like I said,
you know,
surgery is,
is,
is the treatment for appendicitis.
But in the future,
maybe it's sad to biotics,
maybe it's changing into your diet.
Maybe you know,
all those things.
We don't know because we never thought about it or studied it.
So there's great information coming out of that.
Okay.
Final question and then I think that we need to wrap up,
although we do have a couple more here.
Um,
there was one anonymized question that came in asking about single payer systems
like the,
excuse me,
single pair systems like the European economies that you noted,
which spend less but have higher quality of care.
Um,
are these economies are often,
or excuse me,
these systems are often accused of being overly costly for the country.
Do you think that a singer,
single payer model could work in a country like the United States?
A Nice,
easy question for you.
That's beyond my scope.
Um,
but you know,
I'm not a great businessperson.
Economists may be able to answer that question better.
Well,
doctor chatter,
Polly,
thank you so much for being here.
We're delighted to have you and we very much look forward to both the book
coming out and hearing more about what you're doing with AI and healthcare in
the future.
So thank you so much.
Yes,
thank you.